[Music]
hello on a very warm welcome indeed to
quadriga and this week all eyes here in
Germany have been on the western city of
Zoar Lyngen where 25 years ago a racist
US an attack on the house of a Turkish
family left two women dead and three
girls also dead 14 others were injured
German Chancellor Angela Merkel and
Turkish Foreign Minister Bev Lucia
Vaishali took part in ceremonies that
commemorated the events of May the 29
1993 when four young men said the house
ablaze it was one of the worst far-right
atrocities in Germany's post-war history
remarkably the survivors of the attack
chose to stay in sewing and saying this
is where our children were born and this
is our home well a quarter of a century
has now passed since the terrible
tragedy and we ask here on quadriga 25
years after zola gun has Germany changed
and to discuss that question I'm joined
here in the studio by Alan Posner a
regular commentator for the berlin-based
daily devote to says yes Germany has
changed and changed for the worse
racism and Islamophobia now have a voice
in Parliament Turks respond with anger
and alienation also with us is yaz Amin
air game a freelance journalist born
here in Germany but with Turkish roots
she makes features for some of Germany's
leading TV channels and yes Amin argues
that in times of growing divisions it
was an important political signal that
Chancellor Merkel commemorated the
attack together with Turkey's foreign
minister and a warm welcome to to
Deutsche Welle Sonia akka an expert on
Turkish German relations formerly based
in Ankara now with DW here in Berlin and
deya believes that 25 years after Zola
and xenophobia racism at Islamophobic
rhetoric a suddenly mainstream this
Chancellor Merkel said they are playing
with fire
thank you all three for being with me
here today and here on quadriga and yes
I mean again I'd like to begin with you
if I might with a simple question what
does only good mean to you Wellington
was of course the major attack in a
series of attacks that changed the way
that people like me felt about living in
Germany I was a teenager when sorting in
happened and I know of course I remember
it all very vividly there was the attack
and mine before that of course highest
varada like all these attacks in eastern
Germany that were already worrying but
it didn't have so much to do with us who
had lived in Germany all our lives
living in the western part yes yes
I mean people with a migrant background
who were born and raised in Germany who
considered Germany their home and which
I still do of course but yeah those
attacks they were frightening they were
shocking of course and and they were
very confusing how did you talk about
the attacks in your family to be honest
I don't quite remember how we talked
about them what I do remember is that
the attitude that my parents had slowly
shifted it wasn't like a media they
didn't say Oh from now on we don't feel
safe in this country but there was the
slow shift where whereas like in the
past my parents very easily befriended
their giant German co-workers but then
in the mid 90s they started feeling more
comfortable in their mosque community
for example and they started being more
suspicious about who I was friends with
and where I was going and those sorts of
things what I do remember more when when
you asked me about how was it discussed
I remember how it was discussed in
school because I was a high school
student at the time and one very vivid
memory that I have
that I'm not sure if it was after the
moon attacks or after the soling and
attacks but we were sitting in class and
then there was I I don't know I think it
was the German teacher or the history
teacher and he addressed me and asked me
how does this make you feel how are you
feeling and I know it came from a good
place but I remember thinking why are
you only asking me this should shouldn't
affect you everyone here this is not
just I'm part of this classroom and part
of this city of this society why do I
have to and it was difficult emotions of
course so it was difficult to talk about
it and I felt a little helpless thinking
why do I have to carry this weight all
by myself why you know everyone should
be shocked yeah so that was that's one
memory that I don't you haven't I think
it's very characteristic actually for
the way we discuss Ellen Ellen Posner
take us back to 1993 the mood of the
times if you would from your perspective
yeah well um it was just after
reunification I mean it was four years
banned and indeed we there was this kind
of feeling in the West that racism was a
problem of the East I experienced a good
friend of mine who was and who was in
East German and we'd correspond it
before the wall came down the wall came
down I invited him to my house and
showed him but then I went with him to
court spec which at that time wasn't the
Sheik place it is now but was full of
people with from Turkey and and and
showed him the place and I like being
there right because I went to
restaurants and so on my you know my
daughter lives there now and and he came
out of one of these places and he said
I've always be was a member of the East
German Communist Party he said I've
always been in favor of unification but
I am against reunification now I'm in
favorite because we can work together
against these people this is a communist
someone you know and who was supposed to
be for the brotherhood of man and woman
and he was talking like that so that was
the feeling and when as you say this
this thing happened in zoning and there
there was no this can't happen here
but it had that was a big shock when you
Salling it 25 years ago does it seem
like something that happened in another
place at another time or does it seem
like something that is relevant for
today's Germany it's unfortunately
relevant for today's Germany I mean
we're talking about swelling and and yes
the ceremony where Chancellor Merkel
attendance was really critical and
historic I think but for me I'm in
Germany for 910 years now I have
witnessed as a journalist when the
neo-nazi serial murder came out the NSU
and I mean let me just explain for the
viewers this was that this is a
terrorist cell operating out of eastern
Germany they went on a killing spree of
you so will it's the term that is very
often used between 2000 and 2007 killing
10 people a German police woman a Greek
gentleman and and and eight people of
Turkish roots so yes and for me it was
it was quite shocking all the
information which came out in 2011 it is
still and I think we're witnessing more
and more anti-semitic sena phobic
Islamophobic rhetoric which is becoming
you know scary it's becoming mainstream
and I think it's it's for me as a
journalist it's very important to
witness how this issue is being dealt by
political parties and the government and
the state institutions and expert and
journalists so it's it's it's still a
big threat for the German society and
it's interesting to see how makkal dealt
with it in souling and I think the
speech he made I read it three times and
I wondered oh who who wrote this because
I'm sure she she had her contribution as
well but all each line and it's
unfortunate I have to say it's sad that
the Turkish press didn't really cover it
it should have been you know I would
have published a whole speech because
each sentence was was
but the Turks here in Germany want to
hear they were wanting they were
expecting this messages to be given for
more than 25 years
Chancellor Merkel in just a second a
little bit more the so league announced
an attack back in 1993 became a symbol
of hostility to foreigners a symbol of
xenophobia the amazing thing is how the
survivors have responded the arson
incident Enzo Lehmann was one of the
most fateful racist attacks on
immigrants and refugees in Germany
during the 1990s mebroot again she lost
five family members back then to this
day her home is protected by careful
security measures still she has
repeatedly called for peace and
reconciliation
my wish is for us to look to the future
for us to treat each other humanely and
set an example for our young people so
many of my compatriots live in Germany I
wish for us to deal with each other in a
respectful and friendly way MEP Luda
Kench has lived in Germany for 48 years
she would never dream of leaving zoeland
she even became a German citizen
following the attack and she warns
emphatically against allowing the
Memorial Day to be used for a political
agenda so what kind of message is coming
from Zoli
well before we talk about the message
coming from silicon let's talk about
revolute again to a remarkable woman
where do you think that that humanity
and that strength come from oh that's a
difficult question yeah she's a very
remarkable woman it was very impressive
especially then right after the attacks
that if I remember it correctly just a
few days after the attacks she called
for unity and she called for peace and
she emphasized the Germany was still her
home I think she's just a remarkable
woman with a big heart who didn't want
to let hate win I don't know it's
difficult question to answer
who can even begin to tell me where the
hate comes from there was hate then
there is hate now where does it come
from yeah well we define it as hate I
want to differentiate it a little bit
there is some political ideological
leaders who are manipulating you know
populist people who are manipulating
tears and grievances of some people
putting aside the ideological political
aspect because we cannot hide that
Germany has a problem with far-right
ideology but I would want to focus on
the people who voted for for example
I've stayed the alternative for Germany
the far-right populist yes when we speak
to them and we ask them for example you
know why did you vote they are angry
they have a lost we're always talking
about you know integration of immigrants
and but the reality is that some Germans
have a problem with integrating into
modern Germany and we have to accept the
fact that Germany has changed and those
people don't identify themselves with
with Germany and with
Germany's values and it's a problem of
integration Germany has changed Alan you
used you use interesting just let's talk
about Chancellor Merkel because her
response to this - or her contribution
to those ceremonies this past week
installing an in around Seoul again the
attack in Seoul agam were very very
different from Helmut Kohl at the time
of the original attacks and that's a
very important point so something has
changed and has changed for the better
that's true I mean Helmut Kohl was asked
whether he would attend the funeral of
the victims which was held in in in
Turkey I think or some of them and he
said I'm not going to I'm not in favor
of of burial tourism or something like
that
Dolan's torrents of condolence tourism
and that was scandalous and and indeed
Mackel has reacted or acted quite
differently but the interesting thing is
you know if a mother had reacted in the
in in the way this Turkish mother did
and and she'd been a Christian everyone
was said where does it come from
we everyone was said from her Christian
faith but none of us have said it came
from a Muslim faith which it probably
did but then this is this is symptomatic
I think we we do have a problem in
Germany with recognizing and reconciling
ourselves to differences here Islam is
is immediately a red flag goes up
immediately you were talking about your
parents in there and they're the comfort
they're found in their in their Muslim
in their mosque immediately a flag goes
a parallel society we can't have that
why can't we have parallel societies I'm
fine with people of having parallel
societies we have a parallel society in
East Germany you know I'm more worried
about that but still okay let them have
you know so we really I mean I think the
British were more relaxed about this big
they're more experience with it Germany
you know there's a German but Germans
say ordinal this is how believe me order
is half of life there like that we're
talking about asylum seekers we're
talking about you were talking to all
about about integration it is too
many a country that that is still
desperately wrestling to reconcile
itself with its past and decide whether
it wants to be in a an open country or a
closed country yes that's you put it
very well but the point is we are
already an open country but the point is
that the politicians including by the
way transyl America haven't have you
know I've been sending mixed messages as
good as her speech was I remember a
couple of years ago she said
multiculturalism is fail totally so so
what right I mean where is she and this
is really the problem our politicians
are not totally on on message there's
there's a constant you know the other
day the free democratic leader said when
you're in the queue at the Baker's you
want to know that the person with the
dark skin in front of you is actually
legally here why would I want to know
that why wouldn't I want to know that
the person with a white skin in front of
me isn't the neon see you this is the
kind of talk that still goes on and we
had a prayer mean we had a president a
couple of years ago who said that Islam
is a part of Germany and and that like
many people reacted very angrily to that
and now we have leading politicians and
the newly formed Parliament that were
very quick to you know to take that back
and and and emphasize that Islam is not
a part of Germany so yeah I mean I would
say many things have changed for the
better if you compare Cole's reaction I
mean you really can't beat that I mean
he said he had better things to do and
and now of course that would be
unimaginable but there's still this yeah
the the progress is always how do you
say one step because yes politicians
today and they I am obviously I'm
talking about the center parties here
they are I mean they're very careful to
not I mean when it comes to racism when
it comes to race that race
the text when it comes to xenophobia
they are very careful to you know to
express that that's not what Germany is
about but then on the other hand you
have parties like the Christian
socialist Union and they are very oh
yeah they're trying to they're
struggling with the FT and and reacting
in a way where they are almost competing
with them are trying to compensate so
yeah it's it's difficult it's not a
smooth progress
okay well people might be wondering what
does president air21 the Turkish
president have to say about all of this
here is one of his core messages it has
to be done before integration must be
done but I say no to assimilation
what would you say he doesn't mean I'm
curious about what do you do you think
that Germany is trying to force Turks to
assimilate in Germany rather than to
integrate a tough question I know I
don't think that Germany is forcing
Turks to assimilate but I do think that
Germany is always putting Turks also a
poor migrants but mostly Turks on the
test so it's not so much about
assimilating integration is enough but
you have to prove very hard that you are
integrated so every little slip
for example if as you I don't know you
will talk about it probably in a minute
I feel like we are questioned every day
how well integrated are you can you
prove it what you think about air
demands so you're nothing no it's it's
it's really amazing I mean what is
integration integration has different
aspects like social integration cultural
integration structural integration and
then you have emotional integration and
that's the most important part and when
I think sometimes you know what do
Germans mean with integration what would
show I have the feeling that a Turk
could never be considered as a Content
integrated person Germany I mean some
Germans have an expectation which is not
realistic
we have black hair we some of us aware
headscarves some of us go to mosques
this is the reality I don't I don't
understand what integration the
expectation regarding integration is and
I think it's it's very challenging for
most of the Turks here I think it's
really sad when I talk with people who
are well educated we're well integrated
my point of view and if you lost they
don't feel acceptance integration the
most important thing is to have
acceptance I mean if you want emotional
integration and if you expect someone
who doesn't feel accepted to feel
loyalty that's obsession that's not
psychological it's not healthy to
but from someone that you don't accept
to be loyalty I saw I saw somebody on
one of the on a on German TV this past
week when people were reflecting on
Serling and there was it there was a
Turkish guy on TV and it was a
fascinating statement that he made he
said people expect me to accept German
culture yeah but I'm not sure that I do
it's not just the way it's not just
going one way it's going back the other
way that the Turks are being put under
pressure to accept German culture and it
may be saying no I don't want to go that
way I don't want I I resist and we're
talking sometimes I have the feeling
that we're too much talking for example
we started with Salomon and now we're
talking about integration these are two
different issues for me because Salling
in and in issue and all those neo-nazi
violence which has killed since 1998
more than a hundred and eighty-four
people this is huge this is something
that Germany has to handle it's it's I
think there there needs to be really
serious discussion this is about murder
this is about killing our viewers will
now be asking themselves are Turks
actually safe on the streets of Germany
shocking I personally think that we have
to focus on the positive side and we
have to those who believe in liberal
democracies we shouldn't get engaged
until their boats which is full of
hatred and on both sides I mean we're
not we're talking about day we are
talking about neo-nazis and there are
really similar people on the Turkish
side I think we should just refuse to
get it get engaged in their wording the
way they discuss the issues that's why I
don't want to talk constantly about the
bad things yes Turks are safe and Angela
Michael just said few days ago she told
me read against this is your home and we
will do whatever is necessary to that
you're safe
I think we are safe but I think Turks
want to see the German Agency's the
German institutions doing the necessary
things to feel safe here I think we want
to see more and more steps taking and we
are fed up with those statements those
harsh with Oryx and it's not only about
us it's about Jewish people who live in
here in Germany their headlines like in
Foreign Press their headlines like are
the Jews safe in Germany this is a shame
this is so it's not being taken
seriously so what you're talking about
is toxic political language that is
having an impact on the broader society
Alan yeah and it has nothing to do with
whether the Turks are integrated
assimilated or what what was the most
assimilated group in German society ever
it was the Jews and was precisely
because they were simulated that they
were annihilated that was what the Nazi
said look I don't know if the guy in
front of me at the Baker's if he's a Jew
or not because you can't see him with
his you know but he probably is you know
and so this this group which is so much
for German culture cut countries
unimaginable without without the
contribution of the Jews they were
liquidated from Germany so if I were of
Turkish origin you know and so on ask me
do you accept German culture I said well
yes up to a certain point but you know
there's certain things about you I'm not
sure because look what happens when you
assimilate so it's not the point of
whether immigrants assimilate slowly or
or integrate or not it's a point of
exactly whether that there are people
who are willing to use that to whipped
up emotions against other people and you
know yesterday the Jews today the Turks
tomorrow the Jews again whatever and
this is left right center it's all over
doesn't mean your thoughts on what else
I completely agree yeah yeah being
assimilated definitely won't I mean come
on you listen to the AFD to the poor I
mean Gowland
says that I mean one of the leaders of
the alternate Germany party he said
about I
those I mean who can be who's never
simulated she's a member of the
government she she's she's a German
politician and and he said that she
should be I don't even know how to put
it in a story disposed anatolia so hmm
no being and like the Jews are a very
good example being assimilated being
integrated doesn't doesn't protect
anyone when there is hate okay I must
cut in give me an answer to the
following question as Germany changed
for the better or for the worse
since Oleg and Helen I'm afraid at least
the political class has changed for the
worse I agree now I have to be the
positive one and I think it has it both
it went both ways but many things have
changed for the better
yeah thanks for that 25 years after
sowing it has Germany changed you've had
very different and interesting points of
view thanks very much for joining us
come back next week
chews and bye bye
[Music]
you